which we had to introduce way back in
march of 2020
we also introduced the rent and
electricity subsidy scheme for
businesses
fiscal related measures including a
moratorium on debt repayments
and
two voucher schemes aimed at supporting
businesses
and encouraging public spending these
are among a number of other measures
which we introduce to protect businesses
and most of all protect people in their
employment
and
we will continue to strengthen the
support for the years to come
this through also through the recovery
and the resilience plan which will
inject childcare 120 million euro in our
economy
this package as we all know is part of
the 2.27 billion euro which malta
managed to to negotiate during the last
mmf last june last july
and their eu leaders had agreed that 30
percent of the total expenditure
from the
mff and next generation eu would target
climate related projects
as a government we decided that a total
of
189 million euro of our recovery and
resilience facility so a substantial
chunk of the allotment of around 320
million euro will go towards reforms and
investments that
address climate neutrality
this shows this highlights the
seriousness of our commitment in this
area
and our plan is to use this recovery
plan and the cohesion policy programs to
bolster our medium-term vision
based
on an economic growth model focused on
improving quality of life
turning our nation's infrastructure from
being a bottleneck
to becoming an enabler
ensuring our education system becomes
one of the best in europe
making our society carbon neutral by
2050
and transforming our governance
structures
and institutions such that they
adequately reflect the needs
and aspirations of our society
this plan will see the implementation of
important reforms for malta
including those related to the
carbonization a crucial topic in today's
world waste management
transport education
and labor market pathways digital
and innovative transformation
and
naturally health
our government is also working towards
fostering a digital smart
and resilient economy
by contributing towards the modern iseo
flagship
through investment in the digitalization
of healthcare
government
e-services
and in the course of justice
as well as by enabling the digital
intensification of operations in the
private sector
malta already ranks fifth in the digital
economy and society index performing
above the eu average in all the five
dimensions of this index
and
whilst the challenges we face are not
small they're not small at all
and our potential may be somewhat
limited
our effort is not insignificant
nor lacking
my government is equally committed to
instilling behavioural changes
towards more climate-friendly and
sustainable practices
as part
of our holistic drive for malta to
become a carbon neutral and resilient
island
in the face of increasing climate change
pressures the plan
will aim to contribute towards the
renovateu flagship
through reforms and investments
in the renovation and greening of public
and private sector buildings
as well as the power pu flagship through
investment in the construction of a
pilot near carbon neutral school
which will serve as a model for future
proof learning experiences to students
as well
as true investment in innovative
res-powered public spaces
malta's plan
will also contribute
to the recharge and refuel eu flagship
through the promotion of collective
transport
and
private vehicles electric private
vehicles
as well as the provision of charging
facilities
and the electrification of our public
transport fleets
and as you rightly pointed out ursula
and your state of the union speech of
yesterday
will face indeed the gravest planetary
crisis of all time
and
once
we all chose to act together
we will reach our targets
president
from the lion allow me to quote from
yesterday's state of the union speech
societies
that build on democracy and common
values
stand on stable ground
this
is what we believe in
and
also in the other fundamental principle
that everyone everybody is equal before
the law
that is why since taking office in
january 2020
my administration has been in a constant
constant
and consistent process aimed at
protecting the rule of law
the significant reforms which we have
undertaken to strengthen democracy
and the several institutions in malta
that protect the rule of law confirm
this
in less than 20 months
we enacted wide-ranging legislation and
this during a pandemic
including
constitutional changes
and implementation
is now visible and tangible on the
ground
and
we have done this not just by ourselves
but also
with the support and recognition of the
eu institutions and agencies
and this reform program is ongoing
an interesting development which we will
launch
in the coming days
is an anti-slav bill
and the number of other legislative
instruments aimed at protecting
journalists and media freedom
and yes that is why the rrf
and other eu funds that our country has
been allocated are so important for us
these funds will help us drive forward
our plans to continue to expand public
investment
in our recovery and resilience plan
yes
it did take us slightly longer to submit
our plan to the european commission that
that is effect
but our aim from from the first from the
initial stages was
not to submit and just rewrite or tick
boxes
but to prepare our proposals carefully
they must work for us as a country
so we negotiated
hard but fairly
i am pleased to announce that the plan
was immediately endorsed by the
commission
without any delay
which clearly confirms the credibility
and commitment
of the maltese government
as we now look forward to presenting our
next national budget in the coming weeks
malta looks ahead at 2022
with the lowest unemployment rate in its
history
the highest employment rate ever
and the strongest quarterly investment
and economic growth rate so far
our objective is
not just
to react to the pandemic
rather
we aim to embark on a long-term plan
that leads to a better quality of life
for our citizens
for all those who call malta their home
we want to put the needs of our people
and our communities first
and to echo your words president
wonderland we want the best value for
our economies but we also we also want
the best value
for our citizens
we are doing this because we want to
contribute towards the greener
more digital
and the more resilient europe
thank you once again president van der
lion for your visit and your constant
support thank you indeed thank you so
much dear prime minister robert thank
you for the very warm welcome and thank
you very much for the visit we had
beforehand at the multi-information
technology agency
very fascinating uh to see the work that
has been done over the last 12 months
in improving cyber security and it shows
that it is a hallmark of the country's
digital future that we have seen and
visited today i want to focus indeed
also on the reason why i'm here today
and that is next generation eu
the recovery plan for europe
it is indeed more than a recovery plan
it is also reshaping our continent for
decades ahead and what we're doing is
we're basically making the european
green deal a reality through the
investment
we are digitizing our economies and
societies like we've never done before
and it will spur our recovery from the
pandemic the economic
impact on the pandemic through the
pandemic that malta needs and that
europe needs the plan is worth 800
billion euros in today's prices so a
really kick start again for our
economies after a very difficult time
so the reason why i'm here today is that
i'm happy
to announce
that the european commission has decided
to give its green light to malta's
recovery and resilience plan
it follows indeed a very good
cooperation between our teams a thorough
assessment by the commission
and the reforms and investment it
foresees will certainly as you have
described accelerate the green and the
digital transitions in malta
this plan excels by the fact that um
54
of the plan will support our green
objectives
so this is one of the greenest plan the
commission has approved so far
and there is investment to just give a
few examples in large-scale renovation
there's investment in renovation of
buildings of the the installment of
solar panels just to name a few topics
the plan also promotes more circularity
and of course it promotes important
reforms also
in the construction sector and in the
demolition sector so a lot of topics
that really pay into the question of
serving the european green deal
you mentioned uh the new zealand mission
buses you mentioned the car-free areas
in the city
um you mentioned the construction of
ferry landing sites in support of clean
ferries that cruise through malta's
waters i've just seen an example for
that so this is the future
the maltese plan will also dedicate
significant
resources to our other landmark goal and
that is the digital transition
and i was glad to see in the um center
the agency this morning how your digital
future will look like with 25 of the
plans budget dedicated to this goal um
indeed next generation eu will make
public administration and services more
efficient and more accessible
especially in justice and health care
the plan will also help maltese
businesses to go digital
and invest in online courses for all by
promoting a new e-college platform
i want to commend the health care
dimension in your plan
you have planned reforms to attract
and to retain health workers coming from
abroad to care for maltese patients
and the plan foresees investments in
modern innovative cancer treatment so
all this is in line with also the eu
priorities for health and good news for
the maltese people
in short the plan clearly meets the
demanding criterias we have jointly
established
the commission's approval is an
important milestone
for the disbursement of the uh 316
million euro over the next years but
it is only the beginning what is
necessary now is the council approval
and then the work begins with
implementation of the plan the
investments and the crucial reforms
and the reforms we have in next
generation eu on one side the investment
on the other side the reforms
the reforms to build a robust economy
are first and foremost built on trust
trust makes business and investment
thrive
trust in free and independent media
trust in the independent and efficient
judicial system and therefore we have as
you mentioned agreed on reforms that are
crucial in the plan first and foremost
it is about strengthening the
independence and the efficiency of the
national justice and prosecution system
this should also lead to a more
effective fight against corruption
secondly the plan includes measures to
curb aggressive tax planning practices
and thirdly it includes reforms to
further combat money laundering
all these reforms are like in any other
plan linked to milestones so the
implementation is linked to the
disbursement of money and the commission
is of course ready to support your
efforts and to help you accelerate these
reforms
so now i am happy to hand you over hand
over to you the approval of the maltese
recovery in prison
thank you
it's very important
thank you
recovering resilience plan key priority
areas why as a government did you choose
these priorities and how beneficial are
these funds from water
thank you glenn
because
a very simple answer it was the natural
choice
for a government committed towards
improving the quality of lives of all
those the quality of life of all those
who call malta home
so
how did this then translate into
concrete examples how did all this all
this important principle translate into
practice
improving the quality of life by
ensuring
the resilience of our healthcare system
a concrete example of how we will then
transform
that principle into concrete action
is the fonts which are allocated
in under the rrp
towards the setting up
of a new blood tissue and
cell center for malta
that
will cater for all the blood needs
of the country
another concrete example is the amount
of investment which will get through
the rp and the setting up the building
and and the eventual
equipment which will be installed in our
new outpatient building at mataday
the second area which we're
very much focused on is climate change
let's commit to the carbonizing our
transport that is a key area which our
government is focused on
the the carbonizing of
the private fleet of our
of the fleet of vehicles used for our
public transport and
how will we get there we will get there
by
giving incentives as we already are to
users of traditional ice vehicles
to indeed make the crucial fundamental
change to using electric vehicles the
second area where where the rrp will be
will focus on is
changing our public transport system to
a fully electric fleet that will bring
about other changes we will need to
install more charging points we do not
have enough charging points at the
moment but that is part of the natural
process and yes indeed that is where the
funds the childcare 120 million euro
funds allocated under the the rf indeed
come in very handy a third area
which is equally important for us it was
also mentioned by the president the area
of digitalization and do we see
digitalization as something abstract not
at all
we believe that the investment
which will be made
under the rrp ties in very nicely we
will mention one concrete example which
ties in very nicely to the principle of
protecting the rule of law
and that fundamental principle
for of what we believe in we as malta
believe in
how that will be transformed into
practice the digitalization of our
courts of justice of our law courts
we do acknowledge that we need to act
faster there that we need to have more
efficient justice which is delivered
in accordance with the principle which i
mentioned earlier that that the law is
equal for all and indeed this that is
where the the funds coming from this
plan will be put to good use in in
enhancing our
institutions all the institutions which
which deal with the area with the very
important area of the of rule of law
thank you
madam president could you please
elaborate a little bit more on the
commission's assessment of malta's
recovery plan and how and why are these
funds important for eu member states
thank you
with the pandemic
we had a severe hit
towards our economy
paralyzed through the lockdowns and we
knew that if we want to come out of this
pandemic stronger then we went into it
economically we have to kick-start our
economy again
and that's why for the very first time
we agreed with 27 member states
to have a joint approach to fight this
economic crisis
and to ask the commission with the
backing of 27 member states to go to the
capital market raise money and then
invest it in the priorities we have in
the european union
this is first and foremost the european
green deal
and here the maltese plan is outstanding
with 54 percent um investment into the
european green deal it's one if not the
greenest recovery plan we have
the second priority is digitization here
the maltese plan also overshoots the
target with 25 investment in
digitization
and
digital is the make or break issue for
our economy
and
then we have the part of the reforms i
was mentioning so this combination of
investment and reform is exactly what
was agreed with the 27 member states in
the reforms it was important for us to
look at the country-specific
recommendation that are in the european
semester and here our negotiations
resulted in a good agreement to step
forward in crucial topics that have that
need reforms i was just mentioning the
in the introduction and therefore the
plan has been approved by the commission
jacob good
um yesterday the president in his state
of the union speech emphasized the need
for the eu to build up its own um
military forces uh where does the
maltese government as you know mostly
traditionally a neutral country so where
does the maltese government stand on
this and you know would malta contribute
to such a force
thank you jacob i mean the the principle
was outlined in the president's speech
yesterday obviously malta will stick to
to its
uh neutrality obligations as enshrined
in the constitution
um
so that is the fundamental principle but
i'm sure that this is a proposal which
will need to be amplified by the
commission and obviously we'll be
engaging as one of the 27 member states
and that discussion and
obviously we'll proceed from there but
fundamental principle is that
constitution our constitution and the
the relative article in our constitution
which speaks about that particular
subject perhaps
and good afternoon president wonderland
um earlier today local ngo republica
wrote to you stating that the european
union failed to sanction malta for its
corruption allegations um what is your
reaction to the statement and you had
remarked on the improvement malta has
shown in terms of rule of law reforms
does the commission still see the sale
of multi citizenship to welting on eu
nationals as a standing block and what
will the commission do to enforce among
member states its recommendation to
shoot today on press freedom and what
will the commission do to tackle the
issue of slapsticks across the block
so um indeed there are topics that have
to be addressed in malta
and as i mentioned um the reform part in
the recovery plan is exactly targeted
towards
these topics
uh in our bilateral we have been
discussing the topic of the golden
passport
and that it is of utmost importance to
stop that procedure because we should
not forget that
the golden passports enable potentially
the person to have access to 27 member
states in the european union
we have been discussing um other topics
like for example uh the media freedom
topic the prime minister informed me
about his ideas or his intention for the
slap reform
and indeed um looking at the events
here in malta specifically at daphne
caruana galicia
i will go this afternoon
to the place where she has been murdered
to pay respect
and to speak with her family
yesterday
the college
of the commission
as i
announced in the state of the union
agreed on a recommendation
concerning the safety of journalists
journalism journalists with their work
their work on transparency
and information are crucial for the
functioning of a democracy
because our freedoms are only secured
if people give those freedoms and the
justice or the injustice a voice and
that is one of the tasks the noble tasks
of journalism
and towards the um the next month we
will come forward with the media freedom
act
to make sure that the independence of
the media is also secured so
topics that are concerning malta but not
only malta but the whole of the european
union and we are addressing them
together we are determined to make a
change for the better
thank you
well done thank you thanks a lot
[Music]
you